there's no handle on the door to number
10.
to get through someone on the inside has
to let you in
the australian financier lex greensell
was given entry in 2014
when david cameron was prime minister
and given a role advising government on
supply chain finance
but when david cameron quit as pm the
roles were reversed
mr cameron took a role working for lex
sill
at his company green seal capital
and last year whilst in that role he
sent
text messages to chancellor rishi sunak
in an effort to secure access to
taxpayer-funded loans for the company
after over a month of silence the former
resident here
david cameron finally broke cover to
deny he broken
any rules whilst also acknowledging that
communications between former prime
ministers
and current ministers should only go
through the most formal of channels
but in this case they didn't and the
current prime minister has now ordered
an
inquiry into that lobbying scandal boris
johnson hopes that this will draw a line
under the matter
but labour have other ideas they want
not just the investigation
but they also want an overhaul of
lobbying rules
there is a whole catalogue chronicle
um cronyism at the heart of this
government but it is
also increasingly clear that the rules
of zaitsev's today
aren't strong enough to tackle some of
these
issues around cronyism and lobbying
and it's not just labour concerned about
the so-called revolving door
so many people are coming and going from
the civil service and from politics
backwards and forwards into business
that's obviously good to enrich the
experience of government
uh to bring in business experience in
that way but it needs to be but it's
barely regulated at the moment
calls for tougher rules are nothing new
it's an issue that exposes
the far too cosy relationship between
politics
government business and money i'm
talking about
lobbying and we all know how it works
the lunches the hospitality the quiet
word in the ear
the ex-ministers and ex-advisors for
hire helping big businesses find the
right way
to get its way a decade ago mr cameron
warned lobbying would be the next great
scandal
he's proved himself right but lobbying
goes far
beyond just this particular case and the
question is not just who
you know but will it really change
beth rigby sky news westminster